Hey youtubers, it's Charlie.
So new episode of Game of Thrones tonight, and I thought we talk about someone who's
notably absent from the first episode: Arya, who is on her way to Bravos the last time we saw her
This is mostly going to be about the Faceless
Men in the house a black-and-white the
place that Arya going to. The place that
she's using Jaqen H'ghar's coin to get to
just careful for spoilers on everything
that's happened on the show so far
right now our point of entry to the
Faceless Men is Jaqen H'ghar
someone we haven't seen a long time. Arya Stark spent most of season 3
and season 4 massaging that coin that he gave her, the Braavosi coin
his instructions to her were that she
could give that coin to any Braavosi captain
and it would secure her passage to Braavos if she wanted
not of a whole lot of explaining beyond that
but it's a really big deal
which is why when she gave the coin to
the captain at the end a season 4 he pooped
his pants a little bit
for the most part you can think of the
Faceless Men as a quasi religious order
of assassins that's headquartered in Braavos.
Their home base is the house of black white
which is a temple of worship
so they serve a lot of
functions beyond just killing people
like all religious orders they do
worship a god: the Many Faced God
but inside the temple of black and white
there are altars
to many many many gods. It's a nice twist
on the idea of the Many Faced God
but the Many Faced God is a single deity
with many different aspects
a lot of people think that the Many Faced God
is also the stranger
one of the Andals seven gods. George RR
Martin hasn't confirmed or denied this
so it's still open to speculation
the reason why the Faceless Men are so cool
is because they
you know, for all intents and purposes
are the best assassins in the world the
most highly trained assassins
they're also the most expensive. If you
remember way back in season one
during the small council meeting they're
trying to figure out what to do with
Daenerys Targaryen
when they first heard that she was
marrying Khal Drogo someone tossed out
that they should just hire a Faceless Man to take care of her
but they decided that it was way too
expensive. Way too expensive for Robert Baratheon
he's obviously in a lot of debt so in
order to hire a Faceless Man
you have to be incredibly rich. That's why
any time a Faceless Man pops up in the books
you know, people always wonder if one of
the lords of Westeros or
like the Martells or the Iron Bank
of Braavos hired them
just because there are only a handful of
people that could legitimately afford them
the takeaway is that if there's
an assassination plot going on somewhere
in the world there's probably someone
incredibly rich behind it. They don't just kill people on whim, they have very specific rules
it's unclear how the show is going to change this.
Typically whenever the show does
like a really big group from the books
it simplifies things
so they might just hit a really big
signpost. The Faceless Man actually have a
really interesting history that go
way back to the time of the Valyrians
they actually they started out
in the Valyrian slave mines. I know a lot of
people theorized that the Valyrian doom
is tied to over mining in the Valyrian Peninsula
a big part of the Valyrians MO is that
they converted conquered peoples
into slave workers to work in their mines
the volcanoes that eventually went
nuclear around Valyria were just really
rich in minerals
so in the slave mines you had people
speaking all kinds of different languages
because the
the Valyrians had conquered so many different
lands. As really put upon slaves or want
to do they prayed for deliverance
from death
from each of their gods they worshipped.
Other slaves heard these whispers to all these
different gods and decided
all these different slaves were praying to
the same god. That became the basis of
the Many Faced God
so what you have is, you know, many gods
many faces becoming one God
with many faces, many aspects. The
slaves essentially started
giving gifts of mercy or deliverance
to people that ask for it. The Faceless Men's gift of mercy is essentially the
gift of death, the gift of deliverance from
the burden of life
you can think of is as assisted suicide
so the Faceless Men don't kill with
malice
they kill to help people. So now you have an
idea of why Jaqen H'ghar is so zen
about killing all those people at Harrenhal for Arya
the circumstances for those events were
slightly different. He was paying a
debt to Arya
like I said they do work as mercenaries
so you can pay them
and name someone to be killed. After the
doom in Valyria though they establish
themselves as a proper order in Braavos
and created the temple of black and white
I did do a video about about the map of
Braavos and where
you know big locations were inside the
city. So I might do an update of that
just because that video is
super old. Technically inside their order
Faceless Man
is just one of many functions so not all
people
that work inside the temple of black and
white that joined their order
become Faceless Men. And there are also
women too so, you know, tetechnically you would be a
Faceless Woman in that case
I'm expecting the show to cut out
a bunch of stuff so don't worry whenever we
see them I'll explain some of the changes they
made from the books
I know a lot of people are wondering how Jaqen H'ghar changed his face
you can think of it as more of a technique
than magic
like glamouring. Just to make the distinction
between the two
you know, in both cases you're changing
your appearance but glamouring is full on
magic like you change your entire
appearance. Faceless Men just change their
faces but they can change their facial
structure too
so one is magic the other is just a
practical technique
but it does involve using someone else's
face
as in like a mask. Sometimes when people
die
especially at their temple they'll take
their faces they'll take the dead people's
faces
so that they can use them later as disguises
what I'm hoping is that we'll get to see
them do this
on the show. I know it sounds like a really
gruesome practice but it's actually
pretty cool
inside the house of black and white there
is a series a sub levels you know with
specific functions being performed on
each. There are a number of different people you
might bump into inside the house of
black and white. You have priests, acolytes
Faceless Men and then you have people who
come to worship
or people who come to die. A lot people
come to the Faceless Men to receive the
gift of death
the temple of black and white though is
most famous for its Faceless Men
and, you know, depending on who the target
is
their price goes up although, you know, there's
always the question as to what they do
with the money that they earn
the interesting thing though is that
there is no target that is too big
you can ask them to kill anyone as long
as you can meet their price
so for instance if you ask them to kill
just like a street thug they might not
charge you a lot of money
but if you wanted them to kill Daenerys
Targaryen they would probably charge you
enough to buy a small kingdom. Everybody
knows about the two big Valyrians
sayings on the show
Valar Morghulis: "all men must die" and
Valar Dohaeris:
"all men must serve". I actually I think
you know the Faceless Men
is somewhat of a combination of that like
the idea behind them. All men
must serve death. Arya is on this really
interesting path
we see her recite her prayer all the time
she keeps adding names to the list so
the tease is that hopefully at some
point she will gain the skills
of the Faceless Men and take revenge on
all these people but
revenge isn't part of the Faceless Men MO
so it's a bit of a paradox
if she becomes a Faceless Man she won't be
able to get revenge on these people
unless someone else hires her to kill them
Jaqen H'ghar for instance
in the previous seasons he doesn't just go
around killing whoever he wants
he has very specific targets that are
given to him. He gets sent on missions just
like any other mercenary
so the really big question for Arya is
if she's going to be able to let go
of her desire for revenge to become
this new person that she's trying to be
this new faceless person
that's actually good jumping-off point, so
here's my big question for you guys: do you
think that Arya if she wants to become a
faceless person
is going to be able to put aside her
desire to kill
all these people back in Westeros
ultimately, you know, thinking forward to like books 6, 7
you know, whatever beyond that, I don't
think she's going to be able to do it.
A good sidestep is Jon Snow and his vows to
the Night's Watch
thinking about all the things that he
did when he was on the side mission in
season 3
when he was trying to infiltrate the
wildlings. He broke a lot of his vows
even though it was for a good reason
I think the same thing is gonna happen
Arya. She's gonna end up breaking
whatever vows she ends up making
whatever new vow she makes
in the name of justice. That's one of the
most fun things to watch in the show
is this like, you know, can these characters
especially the younger characters
commit to really elaborate plans and set
aside, you know, the things that they
really want
so everybody get really pumped to see
Braavos tonight and don't forget: new
round of the giveaway starts whenever I
post my episode two review
I'll post that after the episode airs. Be
sure to subscribe to get it if you are just
finding me for the first time
just in case you guys are confused too I
name the giveaway winners in my Q&A
videos that I post on Monday night
so while you guys wait for all that stuff to post you
can click here for my episode 1 video
and you can click here to learn all
about the Sons of the Harpy, that group
inside Meereen. Thank you so much for
watching. Everybody, let's high five! I'll see you
guys tonight